and those flashes of open bitterness
spilled out before the final day of the
Senate impeachment trial where more than
half of senators are expected to support
president Trump Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill for us
Nancy good morning before we get to the
impeachment trial where do things stand
between the President and Pelosi this
morning well the tension between the two
of them has been growing for some time
the president routinely calls Pelosi
crazy and you recall that she pointedly
clapped in his direction at last year's
State of the Union address after he
called for an end to the politics of
revenge some Democrats I spoke to last
night said that they had no problem with
her ripping up the script of the script
because it was filled with false claims
but one Democrat I spoke to disagreed
and told me quote we need to be better
than he is and uphold a higher standard
president Trump and Speaker Pelosi
haven't spoken since she walked out of
their last meeting in October
shortly after House Democrats filed the
articles of impeachment so that's the
backdrop today as impeachment
proceedings wrap up with a final vote to
acquit this president and we're going to
have our eye on four members of the
Senate one republican mitt romney of
utah who has not announced his position
and three democrats joe Manchin Doug
Jones and Kyrsten Sinema who could vote
to acquit and if they do president Trump
will likely tout that as a bipartisan
measure of support as he hits the
campaign trail this year all right Nancy
thank you very much we'll definitely be
watching that vote the Senate plans to
take that final vote on president
Trump's impeachment at around 4:00 p.m.
Eastern Time and CBS News will bring you
that in a special report